ja wir haben foto entdeckt das können
wir vielleicht mal angucken aus
australien geht um corona geht um die
art und weise wie wir sozusagen wie dort
umgegangen wird da wird ein ein mann der
seine maske nicht aufgesetzt hat von der
polizei ist sozusagen
überwältigt die handschellen angelegt
und behandelt wie ein massenmörder denen
man gerade festnimmt und dagegen sehe
ich bilder vor meinem geistigen auge von
feiernden menschen in england die party
machen hier sehen wir jetzt den
australier der
offensichtlich den fehler seines lebens
gemacht hat hat auch noch sein sein sein
kleines kind auf dem schoß des wird auch
ein schock fürs leben mit sich mit
geringen und wahrscheinlich ein ganz
anderes bild auf die polizei haben als
das für einen bürger richtig ist nämlich
angst und schrecken mit polizei zu
verbinden das ist sozusagen das an
ticona bild und es gibt ja er rund um
die bundeskanzlerin auch vertreter der
noko wird fraktion also das sind die die
krone ausrotten wollen und solange noch
ein kleines witzel virus hier nirgendwo
der luft ist sozusagen die menschen
gängeln wollen für die ist das sozusagen
erstrebenswert die bundesregierung hat
immer betont dass australien das vorbild
ist ich möchte dieses vorbild in
deutschland nicht ich möchte junge und
ältere menschen wieder feiern sehen ich
möchte menschen sehen die sich im
fußballstadion
umarmen die sozusagen die gemeinsame
siege feiern die anstoßen und wenn es
ganz schlimm kommt sogar mal aus dem
gleichen glas trinken fußballstadion der
neue link der euch doch mal was wir da
habe ich schon eine phobie weil ich
meine das passiert dann halt und dann
haben zwei menschen aus dem gleichen
glas gedrungen heute ist eine stimmung
im land noch immer verbreitet und
motiviert durch unsere regierung dass
man da wahrscheinlich sofort stirbt und
das muss endlich weg dafür gibt es gar
kein anlass mehr
[Musik]